the European Union's cohesion policy
investing in your regions and cities the
economic and social situation is very
different in each of the European
Union's 274 regions the main objective
of the EU reformed cohesion policy is to
reduce these differences by promoting
economic growth job creation and
competitiveness over the past five years
EU cohesion policy has created over
600,000 jobs invested in the
professional training of up to 15
million people every year to improve
their employability and co-financed the
construction of 25 thousand kilometres
of roads and 1,800 kilometers of
Railways it's also ensured the provision
of clean drinking water for three
million more people has invested in two
hundred thousand small and medium-sized
companies and sixty one thousand
research projects these figures are
still growing as projects which started
over the past five years continue to
produce results all this is made
possible by the European Regional
Development Fund the cohesion fund and
the European Social Fund which together
represent more than one third of the EU
budget
these cohesion policy investments are in
turn coordinated with the European
agricultural fund for Rural Development
and the European maritime and Fisheries
fund and complement other sources of EU
funding the EU cohesion policy is
reviewed by the EU institutions every 7
years before being implemented by the
Member States in their regions the
latest review of the policy concluded in
2013 and implemented as from 2014 is
designed to help achieve the Europe 2020
strategy objectives of smart sustainable
and inclusive growth from 2014 to 2020
cohesion policy investments will
prioritize fewer key areas these include
research and innovation the Digital
Agenda support for SMEs the low-carbon
economy employment and mobility better
education and better public
administration the new policy will
invest even more in people by
reinforcing the European Social Fund and
by placing greater emphasis on social
inclusion and tackling youth
unemployment they will also become
easier for regions from different
countries to work together across
borders with increased funding for
territorial cooperation to ensure money
is spent wisely cohesion policy now
focuses even more on objectives and
results with greater emphasis on
evaluation and incentives for effective
projects through simplified procedures
and harmonized rules
the revised cohesion policy aims at
bringing out the best in every region
making them more competitive and
boosting economic growth and job
creation communicating the results of EU
cohesion investments is essential so
that successful projects can be
recognised and European citizens can see
exact
how their money is being spent
you